sauver son exploitation c'est le combat
de sa vie pour mathieu martinez
agriculteurs le lac de caussade est un
allié tout trouvé pour permettre aux
exploitations locales de se développer
massivement ça a permis une
diversification des exploitations écoles
et ça a permis aussi d'atteindre un
niveau on va dire de qualité et de
quantité qui permet d'une part de
réaliser des productions ce contrat et
bien d'autre part et de se diversifier
pour pour maintenir les exploitations en
2018 passant outre l'interdiction de
l'état et de la préfecture la chambre
d'agriculture organisent la construction
d'une retenue d'eau de 20 hectares et de
neuf cent vingt mille mètres cubes d'eau
le but est de permettre à une trentaine
d'exploitations d'irriguer les cultures
pendant les périodes sèches pour mathieu
ce lac représente un investissement
lourd qu'il ne regrette pas pour son
exploitation située à 2 km du lac cet
apport supplémentaire en eau est vital
sans cette irrigation les nouveaux
arbres fruitiers plantés aurait souffert
de la sécheresse et ne se seraient pas
bien développé devant quelques photos il
se souvient de ce chantier hors norme en
regardant les photos sont ce qu on peut
évoquer c'est surtout une détermination
sans faille avec une volonté collective
et qui a permis de réaliser
un lac qui au bénéfice aussi bien les
agriculteurs que de l'environnement pour
les associations de protection de la
nature le lac est illégale et les
retenues d'eau ne sont pas une solution
désormais on attend que les pouvoirs
publics fassent respecter ses décisions
de justice que ceux ci soient remises en
état que le barrage soit détruit pour
repartir sur de bonnes bases et trouver
de l'eau en été on s'appuyant sur autre
chose que les retenues d'eau qui ne sont
pas les meilleures solutions pour le
président de la chambre d'agriculture ce
lac est un symbole symbole des
agriculteurs qui se battent pour leur
terre évidemment qu'ils ont besoin de
cette eau est et pas que les méchants
agriculteurs conventionnels puisque au
milieu de tout cela il ya les
agriculteurs qui sont en bio et le
département du lot-et-garonne et
significative dans ses cultures et dans
son agriculture par le fait qu'il ya une
grande quantité de culture que c'est pas
de la monoculture qu'on ne naît pas de
méchants maïsiculteurs même si nous en
avons quelques-uns parmi nous que nous
n'utilisons pas le glyphosate à veux tu
en voilà donc et que surtout ce ruisseau
qui est à sec en été quand y'a pas le
lac ne l'est plus maintenant puisque le
lac on avait 4 5 millions mètres cubes
pour soutenir le débit d'étiage de l'été
donc il ne l'est plus la revue la vire
vire reviennent dans les pêcheurs nous
nous nous félicitons on revient à avoir
des goûts jaune dans le tour en juillet
2020 l'ancienne présidence de la chambre
d'agriculture
serge bousquet cassagne et patrick
franquin ont été condamnés à de lourdes
peines très et 22 mois de prison ferme
pour serge ce jugement est un attentat
juridique jeudi ils seront jugés en
appel des agriculteurs du département se
mobiliseront pour les soutenir selon les
organisateurs ils seront au moins un
millier à se déplacer avec tracteurs et
engins agricoles